well they say it was even riding
villains you know they have reasons that
seem perfectly justified to them and why
they do what they do and it's not they
don't maybe think that they're bad right
one of the best pieces of advice I got
that served me as a writer but it was
actually acting advice this came from
cliff Osmond was my acting coach and he
said he said he had never seen a decent
portrayal of Hitler because the person
so vilified by society that no actor had
ever played him from a true place he was
always a villain and he said you know
who didn't think Hitler was a villain
Hitler Hitler didn't think he was a
villain at all Hitler thought he was
doing amazing things for this race of
people and he said because of that you
don't get a real honest portrayal he
said you cannot judge your character in
fact you have to think of yourself as
your character's attorney you have to
plead your case or the case of the
character to the audience you can't do
that if you're judging the character and
I took that with acting and I also took
that into my writing as well you know
everybody is coming from a place where
they think they're doing the right thing
right you know so
that's I think that's really important
actually when you're developing
characters there's a minute you judge
character you've got a two-dimensional
character you know you've got a flat you
know like oh okay
I know this guy's story he's the bad guy
or he's the good guy whatever it is even
good characters do bad things and right
I think they're justified that's the
thing it's that the complexity of life
you know no one's all bad we're all good
you